[Music]
first the action hit the grey man with
Ryan Gosling and Chris Evans then the
Thriller series Citadel and now the
electric State the Russo Brothers have
the next project in the pipeline with an
incredible cast brace yourselves because
here's everything you need to know about
the cast story and production of the new
blockbuster Brothers Anthony and Joe
Russo are still regarded as big names in
the action genre the last two Avengers
Parts Avengers Infinity war and Avengers
endgame alone earned Marvel almost 5
billion iar and the Captain America film
series is also considered extremely
profitable and popular it should
therefore come as no surprise that
several Studios have their eyes set on
the two and are hoping for similar
success above all the streaming service
Netflix for whom the russos have already
directed The greyman now another
Thriller with the star subjected cast is
set to follow next year with the
electric state which is already being
eagerly
awaited the electric state is based on
the 2018 graphic novel of the same name
by author Simon stalen Haack which was
chosen as one of the best book books of
the year the book is about a
post-apocalyptic world that has been
almost entirely destroyed after a war
between Mankind and a technology that is
out of control in this life-threatening
environment the girl Michelle travels
across the country to find her younger
brother she's accompanied by a robot and
an eccentric Drifter together the three
of them have to deal with monstrous
drones that have been abandoned since
the big war and are now roaming the
countryside according to current
information the movie will pick up on
the book's plot but may change or add
some
elements for the Russo's newest movie
the brothers were once again able to
gather a top class star lineup that is
in no way inferior to its previous
movies the starring role of Michelle
will be played by stranger things in an
NOA Holmes actress Millie Bobby Brown
she'll be joined by Guardians of the
Galaxy actor Chris Pratt who already
worked alongside the russos on Avengers
endgame and Avengers Infinity War Pratt
will play Keats a Drifter that Michelle
meets on her journey the remainder of
the cast is also impressive Oscar winner
KIU Kuan will play the role of Dr
Amherst Michelle yo was originally
considered for the role of Dr Amherst
but she eventually left the part to her
everything everywhere all at once
colleague KIU Kwan the other roles will
be played by Stanley Tucci Jason
Alexander Woody Norman and Martin kleba
a number of stars will also be featured
in dubbing roles including succession
actor Brian Cox the new Captain America
Anthony Mackey and Billy Bob Thorton who
is also part of the grey man alongside
Ryan Gosling and Chris Evans the role of
the Drone Marshall who chases Michelle
and her friends will be voiced by John
Carlo
Esposito in an early phase of production
the russos were originally only involved
as producers as IT director and mushti
was to assume the director's position
however after mushti left the project to
shoot the DC Blockbuster The Flash the
russos took over as directors Universal
was also supposed to be the distributor
for the movie but in 2022 it was
announced that Netflix would be
Distributing the movie instead Netflix
and the russos have already collaborated
several times Joe Russo for example
wrote the screenplays for the two
extraction movies with Chris Hemsworth
however the brothers will not be in
charge of writing the screenplay for the
electric state it will instead be
written by Christopher Marcus and Steven
mcy who has already been responsible for
the majority of previous Russo films
shooting of the movie wrapped in
February 2023 and post- production is
currently
ongoing at present it is expected that
the science fiction film will have its
premiere on Netflix in 2024 whether it
will also be screened in cinemas a few
days before release like the previous
movie The greyman Remains unclear what
are your thoughts on the Russo Brothers
past movies is the new movie a must SE
or is the project of less interest to
you let us know in the
comments
[Music]